longus come away welcome lieutenant
right welcome back to scrambled except
this time it's scrambled in Tasmania I
die for the most amazing sea urchins ok
so we will do a scrambled egg we sea
urchins now I learned this would you
believe years ago I was working the key
so far in Paris and it was an amazing
way of bringing the sort of sea to the
richness of the scrambled eggs and it is
one thing that I understood early on was
the essence of that scrambled egg it was
all about the sea urchin button so we
take the corals out as the arch and that
sees you two little things here and we
mixed it with butter today I'm just
going to chop it up and put it inside
the scrambled eggs at the end okay now
these are literally hand dives which we
did this morning okay and they are so
tasty very sweet and it makes this sort
of scrambled egg very very creamy and
then from there so we get my knife okay
just chop
so base almost like a sort of shot
deliver texture so beautiful
now ASEAN as always do not whisk the
eggs okay superboy gonna chives gonna
scallions and we'll use some sea
asparagus that's gonna help season the
scrambled egg again butter end okay and
then oh we go okay here we go over no
salt yet now get that off mix there
and then we go same technique 30 seconds
on 30 seconds off butter is going to
sort of almost come out now
the secret here is to work that pan okay
literally work
and clean down the sides as we staring
breaking down Thanks
no not to season them okay
for a nicer preemie and think of that
seasoning with the sea asparagus and
think about that with that amazing see -
and now I start to get nice and freely
it's time for the sea urchins in right
back over
seojun's go in and she goes beautiful
nice mix back onto the staff
I'll touch more
so
fresh ciutches in compression
- take this off sir
yes I'm gonna do when I get my sea
urchin bra on at the bottom end at the
bottom and then from there
crack the seasoning should give that
nice bit of sweetness
never Barry
and then just on
chomping huh there's always in Tasmania
it flies a complimentary don't worry
about them but look at the texture that
scrambled it so beautiful
till that up and then from where just
get the sea asparagus and then just
slice slice the six burgers nice and
fine just sprinkle that on top you get
that nice little crunch
beautiful
Little Toaster pepper berry there's a
CIA scrambled egg now
beautiful Sara please
here we are
so those beautiful sea urchins thank you
mixed with some scrambled egg and then
selectively you to fonts arrestor
amazing can I try it please take it
[Music]
so good it's like so T and like see but
like creamy I know you eat the loss from
the back of the van and you're always
looking for things to do so those CEOs
that you died for that was scrambled
eggs this is a great I do I dislike with
this one out absolute pleasure let me
know in the comments what you think of
that amazing scrambled egg dish and if
you missed them charted trust me you can
watch it on the link below or on the Nat
Geo app
you